so me and a couple of other people
decided that I need to get a new intro
right people no good joke
you failed you've already failed how do
you fail this often silver how how do
you even subscribe how do you get on you
how come YouTube hasn't even take it
down your channel yet yeah because I use
like 10,000 copyrighted songs I would
have been copywriter to oblivion by now
okay I'm just going to do that time
lapse then I've got a question if you'd
hear me
so we are through
I've got a question if you'd hear me out
in your defense you never address the so
tell me straight
this is our time now sure make no
mistake we are
you
by
so yeah that's it for today and didn't
do too much but you know it's 4/20 and
Easter and smoke weed everyday' and of
course it's Hitler's birthday so
congratulations and yeah I think that
next time I'm actually not too sure
about this but I might build a what's a
free fly coaster right here and have it
go around this tower or something
something cool or some path and scenery
interaction I just want to have a flying
I just want to have a free fly coaster
because the idea for the theme I had for
this park was it's based on attack on
Titan and Marathon it in three days it
was awesome series and so that's why I
got the idea for a steampunk medieval so
I want to have that flying feel that you
have in the series with the 3d maneuver
gear so that's why I want to recreate
with that coaster right there and yeah
I'll build that and finish this and
maybe do a station of some sorts in the
next episode so till then